[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody it's a great
honor to be here for mi t--'s hundred
and fiftieth to introduce you to the
panel on macroeconomics growth and
development I think we've had a great
start it's kind of reminded me how lucky
I am to be to have chosen this
profession I think that economics is not
only an exciting discipline with a great
history of ideas and and questions but
it's also amazingly fortunate to have
all of these questions more or less open
so it kind of reminds me seeing all
these debates by the luminaries of our
field that that we still have a lot of
work to do ahead of us and lots of
things are still up for grabs
not only in terms of substantive
questions but in terms of methodology
and how to approach and how to think
about these big questions and I think
the same applies even more to this
topics of of this panel which is a macro
economics economic growth and
development and and I can't think of a
better panel to kind of give us
perspectives on this we're going to get
started with Robert Solow who I don't
think needs any introduction and he's
going to give an broad overview of the
development of macroeconomics and
economic growth over the last 60 or so
years and then Peter diamond is going to
follow up with micro foundations of
macroeconomics in particular emphasis on
search Robert Hall is going to talk
about diagnosing more short-term issues
or the long slump which is somewhere
between short and long and Esther Duflo
is going to talk about the
we're micro and macro meat and in
particular in respect to development
economics which is one of the central
applications of economics the economics
discipline which has made tremendous
progress over the last few decades so I
will without further ado I will leave it
to Bob Solow no I think better sitting
down like any good economist I asked
myself what my comparative advantage was
here this morning and I decide it must
be related to my extreme age so I
thought I would say a few words about
how macroeconomics has changed and
worked out during a very long period of
time when I took my first course in
economics which believe it or not was in
1940 that's 70 years ago there was no
such thing as macroeconomics and
certainly no such word as macroeconomics
there were horses in money and banking
but all you learn that had macro
implications or scale in money and
banking courses would you learned about
the quantity theory of money and you
learned about banking crises there were
also courses in business cycle theory
and and they were certainly
macroeconomic in intention but the whole
history and and volume of business cycle
theory had no general framework within
which you could combine or and compare
various ideas about
fluctuations there was in short in 1940
no inkling of a theory of aggregate
income determination that you could use
to sort of standardize stories about
fluctuations in aggregate income it's
hard for people now to visualize but but
this frame of mind without any
macroeconomic notion at all what we
would recognize as macroeconomic notion
persisted for for a very long time if
you look at the burns and mitchell
measuring business cycles book which was
published just after the war I suppose
1946 or so you will see that and I will
tell you a story which illustrates it
and and dates only from 1961 in in 1961
and 62 were the only period of time in
which I ever worked in Washington at the
Council of Economic Advisers and and we
the mostly Jim Tobin are token and I at
that on this particular issue had some
notions which were put about about the
evolution of employment about the nature
the state status of the labor market
then in 1961 or 62 these notions were
strongly attacked by Arthur burns in in
a bank newsletter in a couple of
articles we found rather puzzling Henry
Wallach also found them puzzling Henry
Wallach was a very good economist former
professor at Yale and a member of the
Board of Governors of the Federal
Reserve System and Henry Wallach went to
see Arthur burns and said to him and
what trajectory of GNP do you imagine to
be consistent with what you have said
about the evolution of Employment and
Burns's reply was oh I don't think in
GNP
so it was simply not part of the
vocabulary the fact is that
macroeconomics in that in that sense in
which I'm which I'm talking about it was
really born in Keynes's general theory
in 1936 as ACP gu
later acknowledged very generously and
the the Hansen Samuelson multiplied our
accelerator model and Lloyd met slurs
inventory cycle model or early as the
earliest examples of business cycle
models within the framework of aggregate
income determination at least aggregate
income determination on the on the
demand side the worid macroeconomics I
didn't try to date it's almost certainly
due to Ragnar Frisch
and at some later time now if you leave
aside the particular formulations that
people think of as quote Keynesian end
quote which I'm not interested in here
the important characteristics of of
Keynes's economics for the this kind of
history of historical view of the
evolution of macro theory were two
things in my mind first the he wanted to
take seriously the possible occurrence
of persistent
aggregate excess demand or aggregate
excess supply and secondly he wanted a
macroeconomics that would keep closely
in touch with data and would keep
closely in touch with events not just
the second order moments of of time
series but actual events it's no
accident that the evolution of that kind
of economics went hand in hand
with the development of the national
income accounts I think either of those
inconceivable without the other now of
course the the 1936 book the general
theory is all about persistent excess
supply but when the war broke out a
little booklet on how to pay for the war
was all about excess demand by the way
someone someone wants acute pains of
inconsistency and his reply was when the
facts change I changed my mind what do
you do now after from from 1950 to the
middle to late 1970s macroeconomics was
all Keynesian in the sense that I have
just just mentioned and most controversy
and discussion was about accounting for
facts not about points of theory and and
macroeconomists were interested in such
things as the measurement of potential
output the value numerical value of
multipliers the numerical value of the
elasticity's of key behavioral relations
especially the components of aggregate
demand like Consumer Expenditure
business investment expenditure exports
imports the demand for money I want to
be very clear about this the Great
Divide in macroeconomics in those days
in those days was between monetarists
and Keynesian x' but apart from debating
tactics and one-upmanship the whole that
whole argument could be carried on in
terms of the shape and variability of
X's is and LM curves plus some
information about the supply side and
about inflation
Amyx those were all empirical questions
but they're hard empirical questions so
that there was lots of room for a priori
argument and for ideology to be dragged
in
and of course they did get dragged in
there was a sea change in the late 1970s
and that was primarily event-driven what
happened was a period of inflation
without visible excess aggregate demand
what the word stagflation was coined for
that that is to say there were episodes
which could not be understood without
talking about supply shocks all the
earlier attention except for growth
theory of course had focused on demand
side disturbances so neither the
Keynesian nor the monetarist inheritors
had any really ready-made analysis to
deal with that kind of inflation driven
initially by the oil shocks of course
well oil in and grained as well so there
was a temporary gap the gap was filled
in fairly soon but it provided an
opening for opponents of this way of
doing macroeconomics remember I'm
lumping Keynesian Xand monetarists
together and the the opposition to this
way of doing macroeconomics got its
energy from from two sources one I think
was you can think of as ideology think
of it as part of the general turn to
conservatism that took place then and
the other was to tap into the latent
desire of all economists for theoretical
neatness and I feel
this is not something I just think this
is something I feel since I have it as
much as anyone else so after the 19th
after the 1970s paying close attention
to events got to be a bad thing after
the 1970s to describe something as ad
hoc became a pejorative term roughly the
equivalent of child molestation and and
and this is a serious it's a very
serious matter and the all of the
discussion turned to micro foundations
which is what Peter is going to talk
about in in a minute
Bob Lucas made a remark very well-known
remark that a little bit later about how
it would be desirable to eliminate the
very distinction between microeconomics
and macroeconomics there should just be
economics I have to say I think that was
a profoundly foolish thing to to suggest
mainly because it's impossible you can't
answer the questions macroeconomics is
asked to answer by modeling the whole
economy as the interaction of tens of
millions of households and millions of
firms and products all of them different
all of them idiosyncratic even the so
called agent based models computer
models that one sees now are not trying
to explain events it would be like
trying to design an airplane molecule by
molecule for that reason what we mostly
got apart from from things like search
models that Peter will will talk about
which arose out
micro economic everyday research what we
got were primarily representative agent
based models we are some where there's a
set of consistent preferences that
imposes some kind of order and coherence
on observed the macroeconomic outcomes
so I'm a crank about this and and I
won't go on about it it just said to say
that all that talk about micro
foundations in practice turned out to be
a word for less plausible macro
foundations for macro economics and was
more or less divorced from the need to
account for macro events this is related
to the absence of financial
intermediation of a of any realistic
type by the way nobody covered
themselves with glory on that score
but the logic of representative agent
models almost precludes serious
autonomous financial intermediation with
serious frictions serious frictions now
I want to take one more minute since I
think I was expected to say something
about growth theory in the course of
this discussion and and I got wound up
and what I've just been been telling you
so I'll take one or two more minutes and
just say that so far as the future is
concerned and this fits in with some of
the micro discussion that we had earlier
in the in the morning what old growth
Theory established that the main force
driving potential output trends and
potential output is total factor
productivity so the natural direction of
research would be to endogenous part or
all of the evolution of
factor productivity productivity and the
very good very productive literature
went down two paths one using the using
human be cumulative human capital is the
main way of doing that in dodging izing
and the other using technological
progress innovation as the way of doing
that and obviously there has to be an
important interaction between those two
if you ask how much progress has been
made along those lines I think there's
some but but not not much no one has
seems to me have developed a lot in the
way of of stylized facts or stylized
near facts near theories along that line
maybe the truly exogenous element is too
large maybe not but the the thing that
has always nagged me about this part of
the literature is how hard it is to and
this is another micro macro line and the
last remark I want to make how hard it
is to tell a coherent story that has
total factor productivity on one side
and a history of concrete innovation on
on the other how do we go from in either
direction from this story that involves
stocks of capital human and physical and
stocks of labor or flows of labor of
various degrees of skill and some
undefined total factor productivity on
one side of the line and the other side
of the line is the transistor
the cellphone the Kindle that will
replace us all and things like that I
think that's that's work still to be
done and it's going to be a neat
combination of qualitative and
quantitative
[Applause]
thank you thank you Bob Peter diamond is
going to speak next and I think he will
use the podium and he will have a
presentation Jim poterba assigned me the
topic of the micro foundations of macro
and I like everyone else in the
department always does what Jim suggests
when I agreed to speak here my memory
flashed back I was a graduate student at
MIT s 100th anniversary and I actually
remember sitting in Christie listening
to Harold Macmillan although I could not
for the life of me tell you anything he
actually said even though we didn't
coordinate and this is I guess part of
Jim's genius my talk feeds directly off
Bob's in several ways growth theory was
a hot topic in lots of places but
obviously particularly at MIT in the 60s
and growth theory was very odd probably
unique at the time and still very
unusual in that it was both a micro
subject and a macro subject and by
subject I mean the people working on it
some of them identified themselves as
macro economists some of them identified
themselves as micro economists the
modeling assumptions elements like that
were the same across this divide the use
is being made of it were not identical
but it was something that crossed that
micro macro barrier and what made that
work was a lack of a deep contradiction
between the standard general equilibrium
model that micro economists grow up with
and start thinking from and the basic
growth model
which was going to be used for the kinds
of macro purposes not the short run
stabilization issues that bob was
talking about but was actually
addressing things where the micro
assumptions seemed to work for the macro
ideas since the seventies we have seen
analysis based on the idea and this is
the stuff that bob was criticizing I'm
gonna criticize it a bit differently but
we have the same warm view of how good
it is based on the idea that the same
dual use would work for short-run macro
for business cycle analysis and of
course Lucas and Prescott are the key
generators of this literature the idea
that a market clearing approach would
work well for short-run macro seemed to
me deeply implausible then and after
watching it play out over several
decades every bit as implausible now if
I could actually put Bob Lucas in Bob
solos camp for a moment in 2003
Bob Lucas gave an address at a hope
conference that's an acronym not a
subject of the conference and he was
commenting on it's entitled my Keynesian
education and he was commenting on the
kind of financial crisis we had recently
seen Latin America Asia and he said the
models we know and work well with have
nothing to say about this subject I take
that to be an acceptance that event
triggered analyses call for different
kinds of modeling in the early 70s there
were some and I feel strongly Jim Tobin
was in that school
and Bob in his remarks tiptoed up to it
who were opposed to seeking a micro
foundation for macro I think because
they thought it would end up following
the same basically unproductive market
clearing line and Bob also was
particularly vocal on representative
agents I had a different view and I want
to talk about that today and not
surprisingly it's gonna connect to
search theory the late 60s or rise of a
group of economists working to construct
a micro foundation for macro out of
search models different researchers had
different starting places the desire for
this came from a sense that standard
macro modeling involved micro concerns
but did not incorporate them in the same
systematic way with underlying modeling
that was standard in micro and the
presumption was that doing micro
foundation modeling would give rise to
new insights and a better basis for even
short run macro phenomenon the famous
Phelps volume had its eye on getting
foundations for the Phillips curve which
related unemployment and inflation my
own starting place in the 60s was rather
different having cut my teeth initially
as a general equilibrium theorist as an
undergraduate studying with Sherrod
Tobruk it was a desire to do micro
better to overcome the limitations in
relevance coming from the excessive
degree of coordination that the standard
general equilibrium model assumed I
thought that a proper microwave
foundation for macro would also lead to
a better micro as well as a better macro
there are two key Keynesian ideas that
do not fit comfortably
in the basic general equilibrium and
I'll refer to it as GE for shorthand
model one is the large importance of
current income in thinking about things
though exactly what's behind the
stimulus logic and secondly the
stickiness of wages the fact that wages
don't adjust quickly and that somehow
that's connected with having a lot more
unemployment at some times than at other
times the challenge as I saw it was to
have a framework describing the
determination of an equilibrium that had
room for both of these phenomena alas I
can report that we are still working at
trying to do this and while there's a
bit of insight into these pieces not
much and where we have made a lot of
progress is on focusing on the labor
market as a partial equilibrium piece of
thinking about the whole economy Bob
Solow in 1964 gave the VIX L lectures
and the VIX L lectures were as I realize
right now a rebuttal to Arthur Burns on
why at the time aggregate demand
stimulation was the right thing to be
pursuing and the idea that there was
just a lot of structural unemployment
out there an aggregate demand wouldn't
do anything about it that that view was
wrong and that lecture goes through a
lot of discussion of details of the
labor market and does them no surprise
very intelligently very insightfully but
in a way that was lacking an underlying
uniform theoretical underpinning and
that same kind of debate between
structural unemployment and the
for aggregate demand stimulation is
going on today and today the discussion
takes a rather different form because
search theory has grown up over the last
40 years to have a whole bunch of
different models to address different
parts of what goes on in the labor
market once you assume what's going on
in the rest of the economy so it's it's
partial equilibrium and the starting
place for this is a focus not on the
stock of unemployed and the stock of the
employed but labor market flows and here
a 20-year average calculates for a
month-to-month what fraction of
unemployed workers in one month are
employed the following month and the
answer is 37% and what fraction of
unemployed workers are actually out of
the labor force they're not employed and
they're not looking for employment the
following month and that's 33% and if
you look at the people out of the labor
force and there's of course a vast
number of them many of them have no
interest in jobs many of them are not
actively looking for jobs but actually
are available for work and 4% of the out
of the labor force people labeled I 4
inactive in that figure are employed
directly employed a month later and
three and a half percent are now
officially among the unemployed and what
happens on the employment side well
roughly 2 percent every month flow from
employment to unemployment and roughly
3% flow every month from employment to
outside the labor force over that
20-year period roughly 6 million workers
moved into employment each month and
roughly the same number moved out of
employment each month and the change in
unemployment was based on the small
difference between the
large gross flows into and out of
unemployment and the thrust of the
modeling and the empirical work that has
gone with it is to say let's focus on
the flows and assume the lessons from
the stocks will be derived by arithmetic
from having looked at the flows now the
u.s. is a bit of an outlier in the size
of the flows but the flows are large in
lots of other countries as well now I've
given you the picture from the worker
site there's also a great deal of work
and a wonderful new data set called
jolts the work the analytical work led
by Steve Davis and John Hall Tawonga
which looks at flows again from the
employer side so you interview employers
and this is here quarterly not monthly
and you say do you have more employees
now than you did last quarter and
relative to employment the increase in
employment where that happens is seven
and a half percent of employment and
then you look at other firms and they
have fewer employees than they had and
so that's label job destruction and you
see it's almost the same size the
decrease in employment in firms having
decreases and the increase in employment
in firms having increases is very close
to each other
and the difference between them is
what's happening with total employment
again the flows are huge the change in
stocks is small if you're looking at the
full pattern hiring is about twice as
large as job creation
a worker leaves gets replaced that's it
additional hires and if you look at
workers having left an employer job
destruction is part of
that butt quits is a big part of that so
you see quits and layoffs are about the
same size on average although in the
course of a business cycle quits and
layoffs play very very differently so
these large flows and modeling the flows
and modeling how they feed into wage
determination is critical for two kinds
of questions one question is we set up
unemployment insurance programs they
work at what I might call ordinary times
and they play a key role in times like
now with a big recession high
unemployment where sometimes
automatically and sometimes by explicit
new legislation we get extended benefits
we get changes in benefit levels and so
the question is how do you want to think
about those where first of all you
recognize you have policies that are in
place in good times and bad times
marginal tax rates is another example
we're in good times we're focused on the
impact of inefficiency you go into a
recession they're a big part of the
built-in stabilizer that hold down the
size of a recession so how do we want to
think about that and a key part that
came out of formerly modeling search is
the idea that this process is not
inherently efficient unlike standard
modeling of markets in micro where
demand supply the market clears and
things are efficient people searching
for each other workers looking for jobs
employers looking for workers aren't in
contact with each other their behavior
behaved affects each other and so there
are externalities there are
inefficiencies and you can't start
thinking about the role of unemployment
without thinking about that and you
can't start thinking about the role of
unemployment without thinking about the
feedback on to aggregate demand the
piece that isn't in
literature so we're still a long way
from getting to where some people wanted
to start with the Phillips curve search
is being built into conventional
macro models that otherwise conventional
macro models looking at things like
sticky prices and wages and how they
affect the economy but it's a micro
foundation piece not a full-blown micro
foundation model and I look forward to
and hope for a big expansion in the
range of micro foundation models that
will be consistent with the general
equilibrium views of thinking about the
whole economy and the Keynesian views of
recognising the fact that we get as Bob
said events that really affect things
and how the economy responds to that is
critical thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Peter and next
speaker is robert hall who will talk
about the long slump okay well it's a
great pleasure to be here to recognize
this important event and mi t--'s
history mit was very important to me
personally first as a graduate student
in the mid 1960s where my classmates
have all become you know just a hugely
important generation including Abhilash
Dixit and George Akerlof avi nosh and I
shared an office and I learned an
enormous amount from him
in addition MIT is important to my
family in that my older sister was an
undergraduate here graduating in 1963
how many women were in the class of 1963
I think it's you know uh two hands Worth
and she went on to and continues an
interesting career most famous in the
family for the fact that she worked for
the guy who put the at sign in email
addresses and night my kids think that
this is absolutely legendary and more
recently my daughter received a PhD in
economics from from the Economics
Department six years ago in 2005 now the
master of this event Jim poterba
assigned me to talk about something
which he knew that I was thinking about
it was not a random choice and that is
to present a diagnosis of what's
happened in the US economy I'll take the
US economy as the factual base for my
discussion but similar things happened
in quite a number of other advanced
countries and are continuing to happen
so you can think of this as as more of a
worldwide analysis than just focusing on
data from the US so let me give you just
a quick account of the message of
of of this analysis in this diagnosis
there were three factors that built up
in the US economy in the past decade the
first was a tremendous splurge of
spending for housing and consumer
durables which left coming into the
crisis and slump period an overhang of
durables houses and in cars in
particular that meant that we didn't
need to build so many afterwards and
that overhang problem is very much still
with us
second was and closely related to the
first was an overhang of high consumer
commitments to pay off debt it's not
just that debt existed but as we went
into the crisis Landers forced consumers
to repay their debt and that had a huge
effect on the decline in consumption
that occurred in the in the in the
contraction and and it's still weighing
heavily on and preventing a brisk
expansion and the final thing is the
weakness of financial institutions that
occurred as a result of the financial
crisis itself in the fall of 2008
resulted in a big increase in financial
frictions now all of this interacted
with another factor which is that we
quickly moved to an economy that didn't
have the normal ability of an economy to
absorb a shock so its interest rate we'd
had a period of low interest rates the
Fed responded to the crisis by
immediately almost immediately pushing
interest rates down to zero the interest
rate that it controls the Fed Funds rate
but that wasn't nearly enough to bring
the economy back to life and this
problem of relatively little Headroom
and monetary policy because when you
have low interest rates to begin with
the stimulus you can get is strictly
limited by the fact that interest rates
can't be negative
and that gave us the slump and the slop
can be characterized most efficiently in
terms of data and just as a big rapid
increase in unemployment that started in
2007 but greatly increased in 2008
especially toward the end of 2008 and we
have this very long period the dashed
line and the right there shows the
normal level of unemployment current
forecasts don't have us getting back to
normal until 2015 so we still have a
long way to go according to expert
forecasters I don't forecast one of the
reasons is that Paul Samuelson to tell
me so many things taught me if you have
to forecast forecasts often and and
there is a very deep wisdom in that
remark which says the forecasting if you
get into it is always a full-time
business and if you want to be a sort of
an idea person a research person you
shouldn't also be a forecaster so this
condemnation of of my beleaguered
profession of being a macro economist
for having failed to forecast lists that
you slump well of course we didn't for
we don't forecast how we don't even do
that so I think the real test of our
performance as a profession is not our
forecasting but rather are we doing a
good job of understanding what happened
and had we done research before that
helps us understand and I my reading as
a as a biased I have to say that but I'm
biased of course as a biased reader of
that is that we we actually did a lot of
research that turned out to be highly
material especially on the financial
side they there is a paper by Bernanke D
Bernanke I should say the Bernanke
Gertler and Gilchrist published in 1999
is a roadmap and that's not an obscure
paper it's cited more than a thousand
times a lot was known that reads
directly on what happened on the
financial side and why financial
frictions rise
when you have a financial crisis in
particular so I want to defend my
profession against some of the things
that have been said even by its friends
here okay so so I the factors leading up
to the slump I want to talk mostly about
the slump itself but I found that that
everyone wants to know my view of what
caused these problems first of all there
was a dramatic easing of lending
standards during the first decade of the
century that resulted in a lot of new
mortgages and bidding up of housing
prices at the same time so-called
deregulation and I condemned the notion
that it was ever even properly called
deregulation of financial institutions
occurred I think that the one most
important failure of regulation is easy
to identify in 2004 the SEC removed its
capital requirements on investment banks
so what are the names of some investment
banks
well Lehman what about Lehman so the
reason that Lehman was able to do what
it did which proved so destructive was
that it had no limits on the amount of
leverage that it could adopt and we
learned that it adopted a huge amount
and then it fell apart as soon as asset
prices declined even a little Lehman it
necessarily fell apart because it was so
highly levered so I think that the
regulatory side of this is is a very
important one I mentioned before there
was a buildup of consumer debt and of a
form with the expansion of debt in
effect people were borrowing more to pay
the interest on the debt they already
had it was unsustainable so the result
was an overshooting of housing prices
and then it's a house very simple
principle of housing prices as in most
asset markets if it's gone up a lot
it'll go down and that's what happened
and when it happened it affected these
highly levered financial institutions in
a way we learned so much about in on
September 15th of 2000
so there was a sudden realization that
capital had been depleted
it was potential insolvency of a great
many institutions and panic and some
very aggressive and I think appropriate
government action making up for the
failure of government action in earlier
years and all kinds of institutions
besides banks investment banks AIG s
hedge fund money market funds all proved
to be vulnerable to this decline in in
real estate prices there was a big
increase in financial friction as a
result there was an increase in spreads
let me pause for a second d synchronized
with slides here this this slide shows
this big increase in the relationship
between durables household capital
houses and cars and other consumer
durables the red line on top you can see
rose a lot nothing similar happened on
the business side the boom was very
focused on households very focused on
real estate
there wasn't much suspicious or
interesting going on in the business
sector that was pretty much normal what
happened was a big expansion of debt and
corresponding expansion of building of
houses and a tremendous splurge of
buying cars on the financial friction
side one of the ways we like to measure
that is a spread which is the difference
between for example what businesses
charge on loans and what their funds
cost and that and this is really key to
the diagnosis that I'm talking about
here the spread rose in 2008 and it's
still high
we still have an economy with excess
financial friction relative to normal
and it hasn't gone back to normal and
that's one of the important factors
that's impeding recovery if you look at
that on the consumer side you see
exactly the same thing credit card
interest rates have remained high at the
same time that the cost of funds to
banks to
to provide credit to credit card
borrowers has declined substantially and
that's cut resulted in increase in the
spread so there's another friction in
addition there's been a huge restriction
in the availability of credit if you
haven't used it already there's a
service at Google called Google insights
that is just tremendously valuable and I
looked at a variety of searches this
shows that there was an explosion of
people looking for information about
withdrawal penalties now what does that
tell you it tells you that they'd
exhausted their normal ways of dealing
with a financial emergency at home and
had to go to things like taking money
out of a retirement fund which involves
a very substantial tax withdrawal
penalty or taking money out of saving
instruments that have withdrawal
penalties you can see at the normal
level it was cruising along and then
suddenly it's shot up and again it
hasn't come back down very much and
that's again a very important issue with
respect to to the continuation of the
slump okay so what happened
turning to the interest rate side the
Federal Reserve responded very quickly
by the end of October the Fed had done
everything that it can do with
conventional monetary policy it had
pushed the Fed Funds rate down to almost
zero and it's still there today and
forecasts shown here on the right side
suggest that it's going to remain at
zero and certainly the most recent
decision was emphatically to keep it at
zero we're far from the time when we
should begin to raise it this scenario
suggests that that it next year it'll
begin rising but only by little and it
won't get back to normal again until
2015 when the economy is thought to be
returning to normal so we're in an
extended period when the Fed heads hands
are tied with respect to its ability to
expand the economy further so that means
that the normal mechanisms that should
operate in the economy
of lowering interest rates stimulating
spending on for example business capital
to replace the fact that people don't
want to spend anymore in houses we built
in some sense way too many houses
through the year 2006 we can rest on our
or is with respect to house production
we should be producing other stuff but
that would require decline in interest
rates and that interest rate decline
cannot happen because interest rates
can't be negative and the result is the
normal equilibration process of the
economy fails in a situation like this
there's been a huge amount outpouring of
research that I've contributed to on
this question of what happens in an
economy when its interest rate can't go
below zero
that's called a zero lower bound or as
we say zlb there's now a whole branch of
macro called zlb studies and it's it's
extremely active right now okay so what
else happened that's important
fortunately it turned out that nothing
much happened to inflation inflation had
cruised at right exactly around 2% which
was the feds desired level of inflation
for an extended period at the beginning
of the crisis it fell just a bit by
about almost exactly a percentage point
and since then it's cruised at 1% now
you might think all inflation is a bad
thing but that's not at all the way
macro economists think about it quite
the reverse I've said on several
occasions but this is the most
appropriate one Ben Bernanke would
surrender his MIT PhD in economics if we
could have 3% inflation today and why is
that it's because what we really care
about is the real interest rate which is
the ordinary interest rate the nominal
interest rate minus the rate of
inflation what we would really like is
for people to perceive that now is a
great time to buy stuff instead of later
well there's nothing like inflation to
get that mentality going normally we
don't like to see that we want to keep
inflation under control because it's a
sign of an overheated economy well we'd
like a little bit of that overheated
tality now and the overheated economy
people are buying now instead of later
they're doing so guided by financial
incentives the interest rate we'd like a
nice low real interest rate which says
by now instead of later and that
inflation could deliver that
well you can't revoke Ben Bernanke's PhD
by the way Franco Modigliani he wants to
suggest that that by PhD should be
revoked when I said something outrageous
at a conference but but it didn't happen
I still have it I believe and so so
we're lucky that we have this
continuation of moderate amounts of
inflation
okay so we're all these factors that
I've identified are going to continue as
far as anyone can see gradually things
are going to get better the overhang of
over building in one sector is gonna
gradually come to an end we're gradually
gonna fill up and those houses and just
and build more houses the the households
are gradually working down this excess
debt that they accumulated in the last
decade financial frictions are gradually
getting back to normal at least in some
areas and all that's going to give us a
gradual glide path of unemployment back
down to normal but another four years
maybe more with respect to policy I we
the policy makers that we're going to
talk this afternoon I understand they're
all still waiting for their planes in DC
so maybe I could say a bit now first of
all I think the Fed has basically done
all it can it's made all the right
decisions as far as I'm concerned but
there's not much more it can do and it
is saying just steady as you go and and
not engaging in any more attempts at
expansion because it's basically done
everything it can there was a lot of
interests when the Obama administration
came in and MIT economists were central
there Larry Summers who basically got
his PhD from MIT because he took
graduate courses including one from
a memorable experience I have to say and
actually quite a pleasant one and
Christy Romer who has an MIT PhD in
economics were very instrumental in
designing early policies one of them was
to try to take advantage of the fact
that when the government buys more stuff
every model agrees that that stimulates
the economy any economist who suggests
that that doesn't stimulate the economy
hasn't looked at a wide range of models
all of which agree it's a number
question but that number is positive and
furthermore and this is really important
in a zero lower bound situation which is
what existed when the Obama
administration came in everyone also
agrees that the multiplier is higher in
that when the zero lower bound is in
effect so the numbers that were put out
for what you could get from increasing
government purchases I think we're about
right and and that was a big effort of
the administration but it failed
completely not because the multiplier
was low but because it's just impossible
to get the government to buy more stuff
the only government agency in the
federal government that bought any more
stuff was the the Pentagon but there was
no increase in other types of federal
government purchases so we just didn't
do it and it seems like and that's the
repetition of experiences that we've had
before the only thing that's under
discussion now that would be interesting
and it's an idea that quite a number of
people have come up with is that if we
could use taxes to create the equivalent
of inflation that would give us a huge
stimulus and it could be done in a way
that didn't have any budgetary impact
but that's an idea that's a borderline
crank so I don't think it's going to
happen but it is it's an idea that if we
if economists ran the show that it's
probably something we'd be doing and the
last comment I'll make is that all this
happened because of regulatory lapses
the most important thing which we've
made almost no progress on the
dodd-frank bill only scratched the
surface of what needs to be done we need
to have robust financial
with lots of capital when I say lots of
capital I mean like 50% capital there's
no reason why we shouldn't have a
heavily capitalized financial system and
and if that it had been in place and
enforced none of this would have
happened it's entirely the result of a
very substantial enforcement policy
lapse of allowing extremely highly
leveraged financial institutions to have
important roles in the economy without
proper regulation thank you
[Applause]
so I agree with Bob that we should be
careful in making forecast especially
about the futures but it seems as I just
made a good forecast I asked Bob so will
you be talking about policy and he said
no no that's the desta panel in the
afternoon I said oh I would have thought
you what if we would talk about policy
and he did talk about policy sir so
we're very happy to have Esther Duflo
who is going to talk about the kind of
economic development is gonna be a gear
change I guess be my comparative
advantage I couldn't find one except
that perhaps sir just before lunch you
might want to see some pictures so here
is a picture of Egypt Egypt gets in 2010
Egypt got 1.3 billion in military aid
and 250 million in economic aid Egypt is
the country that gets the most aid from
the US except for for Israel
unemployment rate is above 25% and as
you can see from this picture there is
deep deep frustration against a regime
that is both corrupt and extremely tired
both physically and institutionally if
we are given all these a.22 that went to
egypt to africa we could have given $20
per year per child for every child under
five who lives in Africa today so for
some people like g-force acts this is a
sign that we could have ended poverty if
we had had the political will to do so
with this $20 per child per year you
could have bought bed nets to protect
her for from malaria deworming medicine
to make her stronger and make her go to
school more all of the immunization that
she would need and you would have plenty
of cash left over so if we don't do that
because we don't want it because our
priorities are wrong on the other side
we have Minister Lee who is actually a
graduated
from MIT who says that no in fact this
is a symptom this is assigned Egypt
cases many other is a sign that aid in
general fails and that it's useless
maybe worse than useless because it
contributes to prop up regimes we should
have gone long ago so the issue is how
do we say who who is right and it is
very difficult to say who is right if
you look at the a2 to Africa it's been
increasing steadily those are the blue
bars here on the picture and of course
goals has not really been stellar that's
the weather that the GDP per capita is
there is the red line so some like
politically would conclude while it
means that leaders romantically fail
because we have no idea what would have
happened without the aid maybe would
have gone downwards like here or maybe
we have gone upward for that matter and
this is like the problem is what Jerry
Houseman said we only have one world we
only have one Africa and we just don't
have a counterfactual to know what could
possibly have happened in this case so
when people don't use this kind of
figure they use anecdotes Wanda is a
very popular one on both sides of the
aisle one that got tremendous amount of
aid after the the genocide and it did
very well and now the president Paul
Kagame wants to win the company of aid
and had started to do so so one day is
claimed as a success both by Jeffrey
Sachs and by Dom visa Moreau which by
deficit as the success of Aid and by Dom
be Samaras a poster child for
self-reliance of course what it's very
hard to to arbitrate between this
he-said she-said can that we own no idea
what what what would have happened in
wonder if the policies had been
different so what has happened in
development economics over the last few
decades is to try and move away from
those big big questions you can add make
a difference to much much smaller
questions much more focused questions to
which we might possibly have an answer
so it's an it either
so the in a sense the empirical
equivalent of what Avinash Dixit said is
the MIT style theory this is in my view
MIT style empirical work toward not only
MIT obviously so one of this question
for example is malaria
am ia zoo focused question I would agree
it's not a small question it's pretty
serious it gives about 900 thousand
people every year even take a few
ninety-one percent of them in Africa
eighty-five percent of them under five
in fact that's the leading cause of
under five mortality so how do we go
about it well there's one thing we do
know from various experiments done by
doctors is bed nets are effective way to
prevent the spread of malaria long
lasting into insect sea bed nets are
relatively cheap you for about ten
dollars you can manufacture one ship it
to Africa and teach family to use it the
problem is that ten dollars is still too
much for many African family when you
the GDP per capita for country like
Kenya is about three hundred dollars for
example so only about ten to twenty
percent of children at risk slip under
net and of course as a conventional
public finance would tell us we should
subsidize bed nets because Malaya is
highly contagious so if I sleep under a
net that helps the kid next to me and in
fact the the externalities are not
linear because once the estimates are
that 150 percent of people sleep and
there are net the mosquitoes don't have
time to transmit the parasite before
they die and therefore there is no
transmission anymore so you can achieve
herd immunity from fifty percent I would
give you a very strong argument for
subsidizing net patches in fact we might
even want there's no reason to stop at
zero it's like it's not like inflation
which for some reason is kept at zero we
could go on with interest rate story
which was some reason is kept at zero we
could go and pay people to use nets and
maybe that's what we should be doing so
this is a policy that has been argued
for example by by the whu-oh of or by
Jeff Sachs
but then there is you know there's
always a new economics to come to come
forward and there is this very old
principle in economics called sunk cost
fallacy which is what you paid for
something shouldn't influence what you
do is it because once you've paid for it
you've paid for it and these arguments
in coming from psychology and economics
saying that maybe the sunk cost fallacy
isn't a fallacy to the extent that
people actually are influenced by it so
there is the it could be what people
call a psychological sunk cost effect
which is unless you pay for something
you consider it's worth it's worth less
so you can so the argument is that if
you give bednets away people are not
going to use them as bad net but as the
wedding veils or fishing nets like on
this picture so the argument is very
heated it's a very very ideological
argument with very strong position of
course they are dollars involved but not
very many dollars when we compare to the
US economy or anything but a lot of
passion and ideology and sitting from
where I sit this is a bit strange that
this debate is dominated by ideology
because it seems we could pretty much
resolve it it seems that what we do need
to know to know whether our bed nets
should be distributed for free or we
should pay people to use them or we
should make people pay a little bit or
make people pay full fare is number one
what's the price elasticity of the
demand for bed nets did we lose a lot of
people if we start charging for them
second when people so that's the
standard sort of economics one on one
question the empirical equivalent of
that second is if people use get bed net
for free will they use them or will they
waste them so that's the more sort of
behavioral sunk cost fallacy hypothesis
and so on which is something that also
come forward is that are people going to
be used to handout so you give them the
bed net for free and maybe they use the
bed nets but you can never ever sell
their bed net again Oh Chloe no school
school meals or they will always expect
handouts and all of this question in
principle
you could answer by looking at people at
what people do with the caveat that you
have the Jewish mother or Asian mother
problem which is whoever decides to pay
for a bad night's probably not
comparable than someone who will only
get a bad night if they get it for free
so a big movement in development
economics in the last said 10 to 15
years has been to try to create
situation where people are exposed to
different conditions of treatments but
are in fact comparable and the way you
do this is the equivalent of the
randomized control trials that are used
in medicine to stress test the
effectiveness of drugs so to give you an
example here this is an experiment that
was carried out by Pascal in depe who is
a assistant professor at UCLA and a
former student of mine what she did is
to under me select households all over
the place and give them net offer them
nets is there at for free with partial
subsidies or with full subsidies and she
she randomly broadcast her vouchers for
the various prices for the nets so that
people are strictly comparable and we
when we look at their behavior we know
that it's the effect of the price they
had to pay as opposed to any
differential selection and what we find
well the first finding is that the
elasticity of demand for bed net is
extremely strong so for free almost
everybody get it as soon as you make
people pay just a little bit the demand
drops and when you get to $3 which is
only about less than half of the full
price the demands basically all gone so
the quest list is very high so if you
start getting people to pay you will
lose a lot of people second question is
are they going to use it if you make
them available for free and there you
find some sense no evidence for this
saenko psychological Suncoast affect
people who paid for the bed net and
people who had - and people who had to
who got it for free and about as likely
to use it I should say it means both
there is no psychological Suncoast
effect and that the selection of people
who decide to purchase the net is no
different not affected by the price they
have to pay and the third question is
whether are getting a free bed net
discourages future purchases and you
find in fact if anything the effect the
opposite which is people who got their
first but net for free somewhat more
likely to get to buy a second one when
it's offered to them about a month later
at an average price so it seems people
do not get used to handouts they get
used to nets which is why in the end
there is this learning and information
effect going on so what do we get from
this well number one I think we on serve
a policy question of key interest when
that paper of Pascaline came about that
sparked a lot of debate and that did
change policies for example a Big Mac
social marketing organization PS I
changed their policy and started to give
bad nerds away the government of Kenya
is also now this experiment was done in
Kenya government of Kenya is
distributing bed nets for free in the
maternal health clinic number two and
that part where it becomes more
interesting from sitting in an Economics
Department is this gives you a window on
how and why the poor make the decisions
they are making and here the big puzzle
is given that people are willing to use
the net seem to be valuing them why is
it that they are so price elastic at
least at the first purchase and that's
not an isolated thing for bed nets the
same thing is true for immunization
immunization is the cheapest way to save
lives it's very very cheap to immunize a
kid the GAVI Alliance and the Gates
Foundation of approving millions and
millions of dollars on the problem and
yet in a country there is about twenty
million children every year who don't
get the vaccination they should get and
in a place like Rajasthan India where
this picture was taken five percent of
children get the full set of a musician
they should get this is like
tremendous waste it's hard to imagine a
worse problem and what's going on here
well we did we an experiment try to
figure out whether small demand side
incentive would make a difference in in
the decision to get immunized and what
we find this is the baseline see almost
never
no one gets immunized after a year there
is some increase in immunization in the
control group where we did nothing then
we introduced some camps to make a
musician easier some increased to 17%
but then when you start giving this
small demand side incentive we're
talking about a kilo of lentils the full
immunization rate jumps from 17 to 38
percent so it's a little bit the same
thing where you get is very very high
price elasticity for preventive care
which contrasts to is huge demand for
curative care and in fact in experiments
I'm going to spare you the detail of
very low price elasticity for curative
care so people are willing to pay just
about any price to cure their kid from
malaria once they of malaya but they
won't get they won't get a bed net so
that is kind of that is that that's a
mystery so what could be going on well
part of it could be misinformation and
try and mistrust that's not only
developing countries in this country as
well there are ways where people decide
that getting immunized is not so
necessary anymore part of it could be
procrastination the natural human
tendency to wait to do something with
preventive care the cost you have to pay
like going to the center of paying for
your bed net is today but the benefit is
in the future so you might as well wait
a little bit to do it and that's why
offsetting the small cost with a small
benefit like for example in the case of
the ammunition program is so effective
or maybe it's the combination of the two
things regardless of what it is
understanding exactly what's going on
it's key to design effective healthcare
policy in developing countries for
example what do we what are the lessons
that come out
one is absenteeism this is a closed
health center in udaipur district 63% of
centers are closed when they should open
absenteeism is very perverse even is
amazingly costly because it introduces
both mistrust and increases those little
costs that people that stand in the way
of people doing the right thing suddenly
information is important but we have to
recognize that information is going to
be difficult because learning about
preventive care is very very hard for
people who had no high school biology
and even for people who had high school
biology so there is a lot of trust and
having the right message and and way of
diffusing the information is hard sadly
we shouldn't we cannot possibly
overemphasize the importance of making
things easy and this is something that
from the comfort of our lives we don't
fully realize for example we don't
realize that water comes free come come
chlorinated free of charge when we moon
about the fact that the pool don't boil
the water well we never had to boil the
water we don't realize that we have to
immunize our children because otherwise
we can't send them to school so that is
like a very powerful incentive and then
we meaning the policymakers experts etc
make big speeches about the importance
of the Pro really understanding what
they need to do and we shouldn't bribe
them to do the right thing
we are constantly bribed and helped to
do the right thing in our lives so why
did I spend so much time on that
question of health care just because in
its I think a good illustration of the
magis on parent operandi and developing
economics today take a pretty focused
question and bring it all your attention
and your focus and try to understand
serve it very well the question of
course is whether when we do that we
sort of give up on the large questions
of how our economy is going to go and
are we going to get rid of poverty one
there whether we have completely
exploded the problems into a myriad of
small problems and
and and and we are too far from the big
answer so obviously if if I if I if I
thought the answer was yes maybe I would
not have placed the question that way I
do think this is this where this very
patient step-by-step approach is a very
productive way of trying to understand
how the PRU behave why they behave the
way I do and therefore how we can
possibly help them get out of poverty
traps or get goes going and it's not
going to be easy because this is from
the accumulation of these experiments
and experiences that a set of general
principles can maybe start to appear but
this something something that it needs a
lot of replication something that works
somewhere I may not work elsewhere it
also means that in a lot of cases you
have to be like Keynes and change your
mind when you when the facts change
because the fact is if it is really
changing on you but I don't think there
is another way and in a sense I think
there is an analogy between this way of
proceeding and 20th and 21st century
medicine where you have a back and forth
between trying to understand what a
particular molecule do and then going to
a big project like the human genome
project where the two kind of fear of
each other to develop medicines and
there are no miracle cure to anything in
medicine there are just thousands and
thousands of tracks and a better and
better understanding of the human body
and together that amounts four million
of life saved
so I also wouldn't like you to be fooled
by the apparent modesty of the objective
deworming some sort of any very very
small thing which it takes a pill twice
a year how can that be possibly
important I turns out that the warming
kids who have been dewormed for one more
year than comparable kills when they
were in school 20% more every year when
they are when they're adult 20% boy
every year is a lot of years of good
cause in Kenya this study was done in
Kenya and they are not very there has
not been that many good years of good
house in Kenya anyway so this actually
thinks that can quantitatively be
extremely important here and now and
have policy implication few years ago as
endeavor started this deworm the world
organization which is kind of get all of
these rich people to give money to the
warming which is sort of pleasant anyway
and get this through making some
progress in deworming as many kisses as
possible so where are we well in a sense
I think there is a pretty clear market
for trying to help here enough we can I
think there is an efficient key
efficiency case as well it seems like a
considerable waste not to get not to do
the maximum we can to help kids like
these kids get educated and healthy my
personal view is that it can't possibly
be bad for growth in that one and where
the NGO spark starts people who have or
are properly educated and healthy will
be probably more likely to take
advantage of it event even if it were
wrong I don't really see a strong case
not to do the maximum we can and in a
sense I don't think we have a choice I
think that's a political imperative as
well go back to to Egypt I think the
poor are not going to sit silently while
we are trying to figure out how we can
make their economic or other labor
market work work better and I'll finish
with Roosevelt the I replaced the world
country which he was using in 1932 the
world needs and unless I mistake its
temper the world demands bold persistent
experimentation it is common sense to
take a method and try it if it fails
that made it frankly and try another
but above will try something the
millions who are in want will not stand
by silently forever while the things to
satisfy our needs are within easy reach
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much to all four
panelists for these very interesting and
thought-provoking comments I would like
to see whether any one of the panelists
would like to make any follow-on comment
and and if not I think we have a little
bit of time for questions and the
microphones are up front again please
come to either of these two sides well
thank you everyone my name is Shi Zhang
from northeastern quality student last
will you go out my students ask me a
question a simple question professor
Mann cranes it has to book about why you
know the human capital is the return of
human capital never decreasing I found
it's very difficult to answer such
questions not because I don't know the
answers in testable but because about my
experience to before two years I had a
battle Chinese government to do a survey
in Jiangsu Province about economic
growth so I spend happiest to do serving
but what I see is all the local
governments they do is introduce capital
introduce you know the technique and
spend a lot of money to develop
education because Chinese China always
lack of these things but the problem is
that all the factories for in the
factories invest at the China they just
use China as a factory not industry
China become a part of production for
those firms as a result it has no such
demand for human capital capital human
capital and techniques because there's
no design department there's no such
centuries so as a result all the people
have high education level a further
outside not to stay at those countries
stay all those who gas developing areas
so for those developing countries even
they spend a lot of money time to
develop technique develop human capital
as a result they never get benefits from
that
so the my question is that based on
professor solos series the difference in
creations of the work of economic growth
they
don't have it not have stable solutions
in the equations so is whether it is a
time for us to reconsider the power and
a function of human capital techniques
for developing countries because there
is a powerful factors never be going
through those developing countries thank
you Bob Bob Bob Paul I think we'll say
something
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well one sentence version is what's the
role of human capital in growth theory I
[Laughter]
said I said earlier that for the long
run it's extraordinarily important
supremely important to understand the
evolution of total factor productivity
with an eye of course to asking the
question what a country or some other
policy unit can do to accelerate the
growth of total factor productivity
there and the literature has produced
these two interrelated paths by which
total factor productivity improves one
is by the improve improving the skills
of of people and the other is by the by
technological innovation and they can't
be independent because most
technological innovations require some
set of specific skills which need to be
imparted and as production gets more
technologically sophisticated greater
skills
or needed it's very hard from from the
sorts of time series that we have to
isolate the relative contribution of
these or any other particular source of
total factor productivity that you would
like to to think about there's there is
certainly no doubt that that human
capital is extremely important not only
in the growth of advanced countries but
also in the development of poor
countries and the the big thing that
China has brought to the world economy
is a source a very large source of
low-wage labor
first of all employed on in functions
that require very little in the way of
human capital and then the question is
can the investment in education
facilitate a possible may even make
necessary the move to more and more
sophisticated lines of production in the
case of China that appears to be
supposed I'll remember that I've
answered the question in particular so
we have where we'll have a couple more
questions if you can make the questions
relatively brief because I think we have
we have limited time my name is Karen
and my questions for professor diamond
and I know you were nominated by
President Obama to the Federal Reserve
Board of once again so I want to hear
your opinion on the effect of qe2
I heard you said you are believer of the
market and capitalism
and I want to share your opinion that do
you believe the US economy can work his
own way out when the QE the effects of
qe2 wears off this time thank you so
much
the first rule I was told after I was
nominated for the first time and the
second time and the third time which I
think should put me in the Guinness Book
of World Records is don't answer
questions like that it will just get in
the way of your being confirmed
so let me skate around it
first of all Bob Hall said the Fed has
pushed the interest rate down to zero
and there's very little more it can do
qe2 is something more and I don't think
anyone thinks of it as a huge deal by
itself but I share the view that has
been expressed by the existing governors
like I think I can say that in public
that it is helpful in the right
direction but I share the view implicit
in what Bob said that it isn't as
powerful as an ability to lower interest
rates to three or four more percent well
so I think we should bill Carlson 68 and
I'm gonna ask this question of you
Darrin and you can allocate it at the
panel you've published research on dual
labor markets the so-called good jobs
bad jobs literature and I'm curious
whether this distinction between good
jobs and bad jobs is so fundamental that
it should be in the micro foundations of
macro models whose intent is to predict
the effect of stimulus policies
especially when you take into account
williamson's work on the structure of
firms I think that's a wonderful
question but I'm not gonna answer it
myself and I'll see whether Peter
let me just say that a major part of the
flows and the slides that I showed are
flows of employed people going to other
jobs and so it's a quit and it's a
reemployment and that that generally
represents an increase in the efficiency
in the economy it you could call it
moving from a bad job to a good job but
it may be a series of small steps that's
a nice vocabulary for something that's a
continuum and there is a significant
part of the literature exploring what
drives it why it disappears quits
disappear we go into a recession as bob
has noticed when the quits are gone then
the replacements disappear and that that
affects hiring rates so this issue in a
different vocabulary is very much there
it's not in the simplest basic starter
model but I think it's it's the kind of
thing that is recognized as an important
part of the cost of a recession that
these things aren't happening go ahead
so David Otter in the MIT Economics
Department has done some very
interesting research that suggests that
we really need to think about three
groups in the labor market not two they
there's one group of people who have
very little training and basically work
with their hands they do gardening and
they take care of people and and they're
doing all right by historical standards
then there's the people who have
graduated from MIT who are ready to go
out and and and you know develop new
products and do intellectual
problem-solving work and they're doing
extremely well and then there's a very
sad group in the middle who are high
school graduates but are are the ones
who are most whose jobs have been
taken away so to speak by
computerization and they have suffered
the biggest disadvantage so rather than
talking about a dual labor market I
think the next step is the the
three-part the trinary labor market to
get a good picture of what the US labor
market looks like yes please thank you
Mahesh Kotecha Sloan School of
Management 74 I took a course from
Professor Hall I don't really remember
what I learned and I wish I had learned
more of it my my question sparks from
your chart that showed the spreads on
lending which are very high for both
consumers and corporates and they remain
high and the observation I want to
insert into that and then ask a question
is that the shadow banking system is
effectively on its back structured
financings are not happening and they're
not likely to happen in any way in the
size that they used to for a variety of
reasons good and mostly good but many
bad over-regulation being one of the bad
ones given given given the lack of
lending that is taking place in the high
spreads how do you see the evolution of
the decrease the observation I had about
structured finance market it basically
has slowed the velocity of money and I
wonder to what extent you see reduction
in spreads and incentives that might be
given to reduce those spreads on the
business side the the bulk of American
business is not dependent on borrowing
from financial institutions that there's
relatively little leverage where I live
the corporation's don't borrow from
banks at all
quite the contrary they accumulate
almost mindlessly
Apple Apple has 50 billion dollars in
short term instruments on its balance
sheet not borrowing but lending and the
shareholders are getting a little
restless about that of course there are
certain industries that are credit
dependent and they're still definitely
you know there's there's no question
that there's an impairment of credit
flows in certain areas I think though
and I think there's been a big shift of
the thinking of macroeconomists in this
direction that the real credit dependent
sector is not business but as households
and the real questions are the squeeze
that's gone on in the household where
they were permitted to borrow large
amounts in the last decade and then
forced to repay that over the last few
years that's been in terms of GDP the
way I think is is very much larger than
what I would see is a relatively
marginal issue with respect to to
businesses most most GDP arises in
businesses that have direct access to
credit markets if they need credit at
all so or finance they're mostly equity
financed the US business sector is not
highly levered only certain sectors our
airlines are we used to say that auto
companies were but generally speaking
leverage is not a factor in business it
is a huge factor in in financial
institutions but how important that is
for the business sector I think is still
up in the air it's it's the household
side that I think it's deserves the most
attention today from the employment
point of view there's a great deal of
employment that goes on with small
business and a lot of small business is
financed by banks and is financed by
drawing on there's the household link of
their own wealth the wealth of families
and friends
and what we have been seeing in this
Great Recession is that employment
growth by small business relative to
employment growth by large businesses
way down and the cyclic behavior of the
two generally is different and what
we're seeing now is an unusual amount
which i think is connected to exactly
what Bob was talking about the financial
stretch out of households and of banks I
think that get effect the financing not
of big business but of small business
and in terms of hiring that's an
important part of the story since we are
running late and we don't want to eat
too much more into the lunch time I
think we're gonna have only time for one
more question sorry for the remaining
people who wanted to ask questions
I'm Doug Cara Sloan grad obviously the
issue of the size of government is a
huge controversy today there are studies
and economics baro I believe has found
that larger size of government relative
the economy has associated with it a
lower rate of long-term growth and I
think there may be other studies that
refute his study within the field of
growth theory is there a framework for
analyzing this issue certainly a
framework for for analyzing it the
difficulty in dealing with associations
like that is to translate it into a
causal mechanism whether it is of course
perfectly possible that large government
budgets waste resources and and affect
the level of output that way it's also
possible that slow growing economies
tend to depend more on governmental
intervention than fast growing ones my
own feeling about this is that what's
more important to begin with is to talk
less about
growth and more about levels one could
easily make a sensible argument one way
or another about the size of government
relative to the economy and the
efficiency of the economy but that's a
matter of a level change not a change in
something that's potentially part of a
steady state rate of growth so I tend to
be suspicious of all simple
generalizations that go from some
current fraction to an implication about
steady state near steady state rates of
growth if I can characterize that says
he's skeptical that about an answer to
that question
barrows or the opposite I'm skeptical
about the value of the question and this
also relates with what Esther was saying
Esther was saying more aid less aid
wrong debate what we want is good aid
more government less government wrong
debate there's good things the
government spends on that helps if
you'll excuse the expression economic
growth and/or efficiency in the economy
and you do more of it then the level
goes up and that's that's growth
regulation is it more regulation or less
regulation now bob was saying it's the
quality of the regulation I was a little
surprised that dropping a regulation on
leverage which you refer to as a lapse
policy lapse isn't in the category of a
bad deregulation not that the whole
system was deregulated if that's what
the term means but I think on
regulations they were good and bad ones
on aid there's good and bad on
government spending there's good and bad
and the idea that you look at the whole
and then move from that somehow into
policy and politics seems to me
misguided
one more thing this is what they call a
teachable moment oh god no no no no no
teaching the world a government a
government that spends money which would
appear as as a larger government
supporting higher education supporting
technological innovation are indeed
generally certainly has a prayer more
than a prayer a likelihood of effecting
the steady state rate of growth a
government that Boches food and drug
regulation or that spends more or less
will affect the current efficiency of
the economy but won't affect the to that
extent I think that's what Peter had in
mind by by saying he disagreed with the
question Paul all right so as it happens
I've done research on this question
published a paper on it which agrees
extremely strongly with both Bob and
Peter in the first place it was in the
levels framework which I strongly agree
with what matters is the level growth is
just the way you get to the level second
it examines this question of how
government relates to to economic
success and the answer is very clearly
size is not important and you can see
that in Scandinavia Scandinavia has
government's that historically have been
very involved in the economy but has
achieved excellent results and then you
see some economies that have very small
governments that have terrible results
what shows through unambiguously is
competence what we want is a government
that knows what it's doing everywhere
now luckily that's pretty much what we
have
you know the u.s. does have stands at
the very top in terms of output per
worker and generally with the government
that that does a good job of providing
an environment in which private activity
can flourish
with the right you know the right the
government being assigned the right
things to do is a few exceptions like
the post office but generally we this
country gets things right and if you go
to another country and see government's
floundering then you can appreciate them
okay I think I would like to thank the
four panelists at Game four
[Applause]